let's talk about big mouth because I
love that show big mouth is uh and I
particularly love how it's very funny
and edgy but also there's a sensitivity
there to what kids are really going
through and you work hard on that right
yeah you try and talk to
uh Specialists uh educated people who
can give you some information yeah but
it doesn't get in the way of the comedy
it's not one of those after school
specials where you feel everything's
been
um compromised because of the message
yeah I think we I mean you know again
just a a I don't I'm not even getting
paid that much by Google or YouTube but
I just if you want to go to you can go
to uh checkout we went and talked to
some kids on uh school we went and did
some sex education together that's right
you and I did yeah I learned more than
the kids yeah I knew nothing
um but we do I I think you and I did a
remote where we went and talked to kids
and it was actually there was some great
moments there was a kid who looks so
much like you
I don't know if you remember this but it
was me you idiot there's a kid I was
doing a bit with on uh uh you know uh
and but there was like a child there who
looked exactly like you yeah how old are
all of you guys how old are you guys 15
you're 15. okay great 18. Conan has been
married longer than you've been alive
that's right perhaps you are one of
Conan's children
this guy actually look at this guy right
here yeah
you know what it's a type there's a type
of child that looks a lot like me like
dead ass handsome oh yes sort of like
[ __ ] it who shrunk Brad Pitt okay oh oh
it's a child yeah
who shrugs your bread pit and then
weirdly okay okay
yes okay yeah what any child that looks
like me looks like they're 95 years old
and if you give them enough time they
grow into an incredibly handsome
handsome guy but we uh we do take that I
think we take it seriously because I
think ultimately you know I don't know
if we realize it when we started I think
we started we're like we're gonna make a
show that feels like a sort of my friend
Andrew Goldberg and I based on our
childhood it's gonna we're gonna talk
about puberty we're gonna talk about
kids masturbating all that stuff but but
I think after the first season came out
we realized oh kids we're gonna actually
watch the show which we didn't really we
were making a show for us so as the time
has gone on we've got much more sort of
serious about how we how we write it how
we think about it emotionally but also
kind of be responsible with what were
the facts and things that we're talking
about talking to kids this season you
know we have we have a character on this
season played by Brian Tire Henry who
people might know from Atlanta as
Paperboy or he's been in a bunch of he's
such a good actor anyway he's playing a
kid who turns out to be uh uh asexual
um and that was something that like the
internet had Twitter and people have
been asking us about representation of
that kind of character and so if we're
going to do that we try to talk to uh
sex Educators to people who identify as
asexual like start to have those
conversations so that when we're doing
it we we're being somewhat as as
faithful to a real story as possible
while simultaneously not being
um preachy or or too after school
specially because once and you can feel
it when you're pitching it out you're
like oh this feels like will outlines
something you hear that like you're like
oh we're being too like sort of preachy
or finger Waggy about this and if it's
not funny then the the the larger things
that we're talking about won't work and
if we're just trying to uh be funny
without thinking about what's actually
emotionally happening with these
characters then then then it lacks the
the real like huge jokes that could
could be that we can find yeah that's I
mean My Philosophy has always been
comedy should not instruct uh and and
maybe I've taken that too far I my
people no less after they watch any of
my well I watch I watch it I I find all
of your Motorcycle Maintenance videos
super useful yeah
um they're they're
I wish I knew a little bit more about
motorcycles before I did them yeah I'm
always telling people put the pancake
batter in this yeah in this part of the
motorcycle and does that work by the way
if you put pancake batter into
motorcycle engine does it work uh long
tubular dough comes out of the exhaust
that's where that's where it is not it
doesn't taste terrible it's got some
motor oil in there it doesn't quite
taste like a state fair but it's it's
close enough hey if you're on the go and
you want to have some fried dough in a
tubular pipe shape uh what better way
than pouring batter last minute yeah
last minute large intestines for a
costume
oh my God very nice idea thank you
um thank you thank you
yes the pope of Comedy has just blessed
you you may go now oh thank you y'all
never wash that hand